cuando los rusos invadieron Ucrania el
24 de febrero avanzaron rápidamente a
tomar la ciudad de gerson y subieron
hacia la Ciudad de Nicolás llegaron a
estar en sus puertas y si bien las
fuerzas ucranianas lograron hacer los
retroceder ellos siguieron atacando
constantemente esta ciudad y solamente
hasta hace 10 días dejaron de hacerlo
Dios mío Ahora me voy a dormir en calma
No quiero pensar en el tiempo en el que
atacaban y cuando pasábamos la noche en
el sótano
Aquí no hay gas pero tenemos calefacción
de leña pero no lo suficiente solo como
para un mes no sé qué vamos a hacer
exactamente
es como sobrevivir al invierno
especialmente porque desde abril están
sin agua y las autoridades como
alternativa trajeron agua de uno de los
ríos pero era salada lo que ha llevado a
que la mayoría de las tuberías de la
ciudad estén dañadas las están cambiando
pero temen que no van a llegar a tiempo
para dar no solamente agua sino también
calefacción a la mayoría de las casas
mi apartamento está destruido totalmente
y robaron lo que quedó tengo 69 años y
ahora mismo no tengo nada
el gobierno ucraniano ha invitado a la
gente de gerson pero también de Nicolás
a reubicarse durante el invierno sin
embargo lo que nos cuentan aquí es que
no solamente la gente no se va sino que
mucha otra está llegando desde fuera de
Ucrania o de otros lugares del país
porque dicen que al fin y al cabo está
su casa
Yo entiendo que en otros lugares pueden
ayudarnos pero este es el lugar a donde
pertenezco la manera como hablo mi
lengua todo es mío aquí pertenezco